foreign
CBD THC and this is of personal interest
to me because I find that THC
specifically helps me tremendously with
turning down the volume on the
rumination that tends to be associated
with
really horrible sleep onset insomnia it
tones down the chatter tremendously for
me and I find that at least subjectively
to be one of the primary reasons it
helps me to sleep
however I've often wondered if I'm
taking say smaller what I would consider
smaller doses in the forms of Edibles
which are then converted through first
pass metabolism into other things but
at 2.5 milligrams or 5 milligrams or
seven and a half milligrams am I
inhibiting my REM sleep coming back to
what you said earlier like sometimes you
don't know what you don't know because
you're not immediately aware of how much
REM sleep you're getting unless you're
tracking it using some type of biometric
device
am I screwing myself in the long term by
using this Aid in the short term right
so that's the context but please please
in any way that makes sense tell us what
you know about CBD THC and anything else
related to this fine plant
so there's probably more research that
we have right now on THC which is the
psychoactive component of cannabis
but there is some fairly interesting
data on cbd2 and a little significantly
less data on CBN
for THC so it we have a set of
cannabinoid receptors in the brain both
What's called the CB1 receptor and the
CB2 receptor the CB1 receptor is the
primary one that's expressed in the
brain that's where we think THC is
having its sleep effects
and so
what we've found and by the way if you
go back some of the first writings the
first emergence of this story of THC for
sleep at least from what I found came
from the writings of This brilliant
British position
Dr Clan dining and he published his
first monographs in
1843 I think it was and if you read it
oh I think you would love it too much I
should send you something before it was
cool wow yeah before it was cool and it
was like this hemp resin that he was
talking about but just the writing
itself you would love it's this
wonderful oh gosh I wish I could write
that way but his writing is lovely and
delicious and I could read it all
weekend but he just he was the first to
describe some soporific and sedating
benefits of hemp resin and then another
doctor the same year oh Shaughnessy
published some evidence too what we
probably know of
four things related to THC with a
possible caveat the first is that you
get a Fairly reliable very nice
reduction in the time it takes you to
fall asleep this is just what you're
describing too it seems to have sedative
benefit and we're starting to unpack and
understand exactly why THC has that sort
of sedating effect
the next issue however isn't quite such
Rosy news that you seem to develop
tolerance which is that the same dose if
you're using it chronically consistently
every single night can in some
individuals lead to
a tolerance that means that you have to
increase the dose and therefore you
develop a dependency and I think the way
if people want to test dependency would
be to say look if I have to let's say
travel internationally and I'm I
obviously don't want to you know Transit
unless it drugs into other countries if
if they're not legal there then would I
start to just get very anxious I would
think well my goodness I've lost my
crutch of THC and at that point it
probably demonstrates that there is a
dependency that you have on it which I'd
prefer or wish for people not to have
necessarily
the the third feature of THC
is that it has quite a significant
withdrawal rebound effect so when people
stop using THC they typically don't just
go back to the bad sleep that they were
having before it's often even worse do
we have any idea of the
dosage range that we're talking about
right because you could develop
DT and Tremors and so on from alcohol
withdrawal but that's not going to
happen if you're having one glass of
wine per night so in this particular
case with
THC
how much does one need to be taking or
do we know
on a consistent let's just say nightly
basis
to experience that type of
rebound that would be so harmful
to sleep do we know I wish I had an
answer and we currently just simply
don't know okay automatic studies right
now it's more simply service but it's
observable like it can happen but it's
very I mean it's so observable it's so
reliable this rebound insomnia
withdrawal that it forms part of the DSM
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders the sort of Psychiatry
Bible it forms part of the criteria
symptoms for cannabis withdrawal this
insomnia syndrome that's how
consistently reliable it is it's part of
the diagnostic criteria and in fact
often it's the insomnia that happens
when you stop using that is one of the
Prime reasons for remittance that people
will then go back to using it because
they just dislike the insomnia so much
and so go back to the wacky tobacco they
can't stay away
and then the other aspect is that it
seems to why significantly disrupt your
REM sleep and it does it in three ways
the first is that it will decrease the
overall amount of REM sleep that you're
getting the second is that it delays the
arrival of the first episode of REM
sleep in this cycling
the nature of sleep
and then the third aspect of that is it
seems to decrease the intensity of rapid
eye movement sleep and the way that one
of the ways that we measure that is just
how many of these eye movements that's
where it gets its name by the way rapid
eye movement sleep because your eyes
start back and forth and the more of
those rapid eye movements that you're
having the more intense the REM sleep
and in fact the more intense the
dreaming and THC will decrease the
intensity that metric of
REM sleep too
I think perhaps the more powerful piece
of evidence for me looking at the
literature that it is REM sleep
disruptive is less about the amount of
the quality of the REM sleep as you're
using but what happens when you stop
using which is all of a sudden you get a
rebound effect where you start to get
significantly more REM sleep when you
stop using THC and that's a
demonstration of scientist that we would
say is a homeostatic response which is
that if you deprive yourself of
something when you get the chance to get
it you get an increase in the amount
there is a response and that increase
that homeostatic rebound effect is
usually a sign of a deficiency that's
been happening before that